Let's go next to our caller from the 6 0 3
area code who's calling today from 6 0 3.
Hi, my name's Eric, New Hampshire.
Hey, Eric, what's up?
Not much.
I just have a quick question because of the
pandemic.
How wider will the separation between classes
become without any policy or tax change?
If, say, Trump gets reelected and.
You know, everything becomes the way it has
been for the past three years.
How far do you think the haves and have nots.
That separation will grow?
I don't have a mathematical answer, but it's
going to grow.
And you're out.
No, no asking.
You're asking a really important question,
which is we are now seeing, you know, that
there's this implicit understanding of blue
collar and white collar that exists.
You know, the idea sometimes is made very
simple by calling it office work versus factory
work.
The reality is it's much more complex than
that right now.
You see, as I mentioned, for example, airline
pilots very much affected by what's going
on right now.
You see people who work in restaurants, but
also people who work in certain types of retail.
And even people in certain areas of health
care that are being hit because they are typically
non-emergency health care, et cetera.
So we are going to say I was growing.
Yeah.
I was more talking about the people that the
shareholders of the airlines, not the pilots.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm talking about the ones that have
the wealth.
You are going to seize opportunities, whether
you know, but not not the person that goes
to work, the ones that tell the people to
go to work.
Absolutely.
Listen in.
At any time there is a cataclysm, a crisis,
a pandemic, a natural disaster, something
like 9/11.
These are opportunities for speculators and
those who have are flush with cash to make
a ton of money with speculative and nonproductive
use of assets.
There is no doubt about it.
And you're completely accurate in that.
There is going to be a widening income gap,
a wealth gap, rather, as a result of this,
because of people who are in a position to
seize some of those opportunities.
Totally.
OK.
Right.
I mean, that's why I thought unless there
is policy or tax change, of course, too.
So like one example.
Now this is starting to Trump actually floated
this, but he didn't do it, which is what about
suspending the payroll tax for a certain period
of time?
The Social Security, Medicare, that would
actually be an interesting thing, because
if you don't remember exactly where the line
is, but it's around one hundred and twenty
five thousand a year, you only pay Social
Security, Medicare up to your first hundred
and twenty five thousand a year in wages.
So people who earn a lot more than that in
wages or people who are earning their money
through capital gains, they're already not
paying that.
So suspending that would be a way to directly
do fiscal stimulus to people who are actually
mostly working for a living.
It wasn't done right.
But that's an example of a policy that will.
Yeah, I agree.
All right.
So much for your call.
I very much appreciate it.
And it's great to hear from our mostly friendly
neighbors to the north in New Hampshire.